i have to tell you you know i i had the
pleasure of speaking with your sister
tamara in october of last year
and she told me that you hadn't seen one
another
throughout the entire pandemic i still
haven't seen her physically
um no i i i six months
no because i live in napa i recently
went down there like recently
we were gonna meet up she's working on
family reunion and the time
it didn't work but i know for a fact
when we see each other
we're just we're just gonna we're gonna
cry is this the longest you've ever gone
in life
um yeah we even we've been we've been
mapping it out we've been like you know
it's been like
it's been like six months i'm curious
now that we're here in march
have you had your opportunity to have
your family reunion
with tamara yet so yes i have
i was able to see my sister um and then
also for easter the day before easter
we will finally be able to get the whole
family together to see each other
so you know the time that i did get to
see my sister it was just me and her
um but was it terrible
yes of course we were so happy to see
each other
and we hadn't seen each other in so long
but now
i you know and i still i haven't i
haven't gotten to see my um
my niece and my nephew either so um
we're really looking forward to the
weekend so that we could spend
time with the whole entire family so
we're very excited thank you so much for
inviting me on your show to promote
c by coco it should be called cheap by
coco
we don't get one we don't get two we get
three
real housewives cameos seeing coco
going head to head with these housewives
what was it like for you to be in your
first real housewife style brawl
let me tell you it was definitely
entertaining
and you know i got a little bit of
practice behind the scenes
it's so funny like even before we
started
um you know saying our lines and acting
each of the girls like walked up to me
and
you know kind of uh you know told me a
little stuff you know
about each other i was like oh okay okay
oh wow
okay and then action you know what i
mean but um
it was it was a lot of fun these girls
are they're so professional
they're so great at um acting
like they were they were so wonderful it
was it was a lot of fun
very entertaining should i say i was
like enjoying myself
my daughter jordan or you know that's a
real name
i like when she goes wrong road raw road
wrong road i was dying
it's it's so much fun wrong road
wrong road wrong road